so we're here in San Francisco's Golden
Gate Park for outside lands this is a
three day festival featuring more than
60 bands now the festival's gonna last
for three days and during that time
there's going to be more than a hundred
thousand people streaming through the
gates now you can't just set up camp in
the middle of Golden Gate Park and just
see what happens it takes a whole lot of
planning weeks months in advance to book
the band's to set up carts to set up
food to set up electricity to set up
internet I mean there's tons of stuff
you have to consider so we went behind
the scenes and we talked to the founders
to find out exactly how it is they can
put on a festival of this size and have
it run smoothly
obviously the first thing is finding
your location and being able to you know
secure the ability to do it obviously
here in San Francisco
in a place that Golden Gate Park there's
so many levels of bureaucracy and things
that you have to go through to be able
to utilize a property like this and
rightfully so because it is one of the
most amazing parks in the world and it's
used by the people the city on a regular
basis so you know it took us a while to
be able to create the right set of
parameters and deal structure and all
the things that you need to for a city
to feel like it's worth their while in a
lot of ways I mean it's a year-round
endeavor there's all sorts of things
that happen on a different timeline so
you know for instance talent booking
happens really early on especially at
the higher levels the bigger bands
usually are planning their schedules
further out in advance you know they're
probably looking you know six months to
a year in advance and their schedules
and it's a long process to you know
trying to figure out which of the top
bands makes sense for your festival for
any particular year so that's that's
really early on process in terms of the
logistical operations of it you know the
first year you do it you really start
way early I mean even we we would
probably started a year or two before we
even launched the first festival and do
it layouts and kind of just coming up
with a general plan of how we would use
the park even identifying what areas we
wanted to use and really get about a
week between when we first step on here
and start building stuff and to when the
doors open there's a couple different
i'd say big headline departments one is
production and production is basically
let me say that in a concert Decimus
setting you're talking about stages
you're talking about the sound and
lights and everything to do with the
actual performance of the artist then
you have your site operations and that
kind of you know
is over the entire festival with his day
kind of coordinating almost everything
so that that entails layout that entails
all of the logistical systems from
sanitation bathrooms electrical security
the other department that kind of melds
into that a little bit as concessions
here at outside lands it's a much more
intensive detail of things because one
of our big initiatives here is utilizing
all the great restaurants and purveyors
of the Northern California community
seventy-five ones we have corn sparkling
wine out here in the courtyard there's
75 wines I bet we have the valve around
a thousand cases the wine out here
twelve thousand bottles at 750
milliliters it's a lot of one there's a
lot of one to go through at about 72
hours we use two-way radios or 16
channel radios for a lot of heat on site
stuff obviously everybody has cell
phones so there's a lot of communication
happening through that and then we do
have a whole IT department we probably
start with a core group of like 50 or
100 you know in terms of our staff plus
the vendors that are coming in to do
stuff and then each day it kind of grows
and grows and by the time we open gates
on Friday with all the concession stands
staffed and all the different specialty
areas sponsorship areas were up to about
2,000 people one of the biggest things
is is cleanup yeah we want to turn the
house the next day so when you walk in
here you know we don't see anything one
of the things that's interesting here at
Golden Gate Park is that you know we're
very you know careful to not tear up any
of the turf that's here so we actually
have special forklifts that are fitted
with tires that are these real big round
tires they look like tires from a race
car
you know have a pretty robust fence that
surrounds the perimeter we also have you
know regular concert security that
patrols different sections that we think
are more vulnerable than others we have
a mounted patrol company that actually
patrols the whole perimeter whenever we
go and do an event we start with what
can we source locally hopefully it costs
less there's less environmental impact
and then probably you know first and
foremost that we want to support
whatever local economy were working in
things like sound systems are usually
you know out on the road touring with
different bands and stuff so you have to
sort a plan how you can get one but we
are actually using a local company for
that this year so really in a place like
this a really good percentage of stuff
is local just like go with it you can't
just do that so we're here in San
Francisco
yeah we're outside man's best that was
rad let's see that again